welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today
well i've already talked earlier in the
show about republican strategy for the
midterms talking about the fact that one
of the things they need to do is make
sure that democrats aren't able to
deliver for the american public
but there's another thing that they're
trying to do
republicans across the country
are trying to create these fake
boogeymen
to basically drum up their base
and get them to be angry
about something that doesn't even exist
recently writing for business insider
manny fidel
put out a phenomenal article
that i want to spend some time talking
about because it's just so great title
of it here is republicans are winning
political battles by arguing against
non-existent boogeymen
and one of the first examples he talks
about is a tweet
a recent tweet from ben shapiro
where shapiro was whining about you know
the updated cdc guidelines recently the
vaccinated people need to wear masks and
sapira shapiro
started going on a rant
about
hell no he's not going to wear a mask
inside his own house and his wife's not
going to wear a mask inside their own
house and their kids aren't going to do
that and republicans got all drummed up
and said oh hell no that's not happening
and then
none of them bothered to think for a
second that
that's not happening
that's not an actual thing that the cdc
said was was gonna happen
didn't even come close to implying that
nobody has ever said when you're in your
own home you have to wear a mask
but that didn't stop shapiro from
implying that and then of course getting
all of his little lemmings to go along
with it and to become outraged by it
and that is just a tiny tiny sliver
of what republicans are doing they're
trying to straw man their way to a
victory
in the midterms
and as fidel points out
it's because they can't run on actual
issues
now this is something i have been
talking about for years and this is the
point i love to make the republican
party has not had a new idea
in 40 years
the last new idea they had this
groundbreaking new thing they came out
with and said hey look here's a thing
we've created was trickle down economics
and i'm sure we all know how well that
worked out for everybody but again to
their credit it was a new idea
just because it was a horrible idea an
economically devastating idea it doesn't
mean it wasn't new
but that was the last time that that
party collectively put their heads
together and said what can we do
and ever since then it's been a rehash
of the same dang thing every time they
get in power trickle down trickle down
trickle down hasn't been a republican
president in my lifetime
that hasn't overseen some kind of
recession at least one recession
and a lot of it is tied to the
trickle-down economics
and then of course democratic presidents
have to come and try to clean up the
mess we've never rebuilt the economy
from when reagan came out and destroyed
unions and enacted trickle-down for
eight years yeah it's been horrendous
ever since then the middle class has all
but disappeared here in the united
states
and even when we do have the recoveries
like what we're in now we're not
creating good paying jobs but look at me
here folks i am getting off on a tangent
that's a story for another day and maybe
we'll talk about it i've got some more
fill-ins coming next week but anyway
here's the thing
back to the straw man issue
shapiro is not the only one doing it
we have republican governors all across
the
country passing these massive
voter suppression laws and they're doing
it they say
to get rid of all the fraud in these
elections
oh democrats want everybody to have a
right to vote they tell us even illegal
immigrants
we've all heard that talking point not
just from the 2020 election we've been
hearing that talking point from
republicans for well over a decade or
two
democrats want to give illegal
immigrants the right to vote
nope
nobody ever suggested that ever
ever
but they use it and the little
republican lemmings go out and they
repeat those talking points you see it
on facebook you see it on twitter you
see it constantly
because there's no critical thinking
they get told a thing that is a blatant
lie
and then they go out and repeat it so
others get outraged by it another great
example
of legislating where it's not even
necessary
transgender athlete bans
right state of florida signed one of
those
oh no if you were born a male you cannot
compete
even if you identify as a female now you
cannot compete in women's sports
that that wasn't a problem we were
having here in the state of florida
in fact even if it were a thing that
were happening it still wouldn't even be
an actual problem
but our governor in between not letting
us protect our kids from kovid
has been working on all of these
horribly
horribly oppressive laws to address
problems that don't actually exist here
in the united states there is no
epidemic
of
people who were born men
and later identify as women
encroaching on women's sports and just
dominating everybody that that's not
happening
enough to even warrant legislation
especially because this legislation is
clearly
biased because it also says but if
you're a woman if you're born a woman
and then you identify as a man later in
life you can still play you can play
men's sports we're totally cool with
that
so yeah
weird
doesn't address a real actual problem
but the talking points that led up to
that did get republicans in a frenzy
they got everybody thinking oh my god
we've got this horrific thing all the
the men are in women's sports women are
in men's sports
who knows what's what
i'm scared and confused and that's why
we end up with this legislation because
they can't actually talk about the real
issues
we've seen it with the tea party
as manny fidel also points out in his
piece
tea party was basically funded by
billionaires from the start
convincing people that obamacare was
going to be
communism or that you are going to be
taxed to hell and back
in order to pay for this two things by
the way that never actually happened
but
they got people to think these things
were true
and they went out there and did the
billionaires bidding
it's the same thing
when you see somebody like marjory
taylor-green refer to democrats as
communists
they're not communists
but you say it enough
the limings believe it the lemmings get
mad about that the lemmings start to
yell we're not going to have communists
in our dang country no siree bob
and they do all of this in fact the
entire culture war exists
because republicans are so terrible on
real issues
they can't talk about the economy as i
mentioned every republican president in
my lifetime has overseen at least one
recession during their tenure they suck
at the economy
well they can't really talk about middle
class because their trickle-down
economics have destroyed the middle
class
they can't really gripe about wages and
what to do about that because they're
the ones kind of holding up the whole
increasing the minimum wage thing
they can't talk about health care
because well they don't want anything to
change and the current system is killing
people
they don't want to do anything that's
actually going to benefit real american
citizens they only care about their
wealthy donors
you know repealing environmental
standards
increasing the amount of mercury in the
air and water that doesn't benefit us
that actually hurts us folks
but they still push this as some kind of
freedom from tyranny
a tyranny that doesn't exist
most of these republican boogeymen
don't actually
exist
but they would rather fight against
these phony enemies because it's really
hard by the way to disprove a negative
so when republicans go out there and
they just make stuff up to be mad about
like oh my god joe biden wants to muzzle
all your dogs out there how dare he
we can go out there and we can say wait
no no he doesn't but they're going to
say but yes he does
show me the evidence where he doesn't
there's no evidence that he doesn't
because he didn't do the thing
so you see what i mean like it is very
hard to disprove a negative
and that's how republicans went on these
issues unfortunately
they get people worked up with lies and
misinformation and and stupid talk to be
frank with you
and then we always end up having to be
on the defensive trying to correct the
record
and unfortunately
that's an uphill battle because by the
time we've
finally figured out a way to address the
nonsense
republicans have already told 10 more
lies
before we could even finish debunking
the first one